uh people are getting used to the jet
lag and now they're coming later and
later in the day
on the first day everyone was really
really early and you know hurry earlier
but now
um yeah so welcome to Berkeley I guess
um okay so welcome to the fourth day and
today Dan is going to tell us more about
the power of algebra and save my rings
um please take it away okay thanks hunk
so we saw during the first day uh when
he presented his story he showed that he
the power and the the utility of
extending relational queries to real
numbers and yesterday we saw from Val uh
how you can get much more mileage out of
extending not to real numbers but
extending GC relational queries to
arbitrary semi rings but real
applications they
um
data science they require iteration lots
of problems they require the combination
of queries and iterations think about
reachability in graphs cluster
ingredients and so on so we need some
language some technique some Concepts
that allow us to combine uh queries over
semi-rings with iteration
now in databases we have this beautiful
language called data log it has been
studied since the early in the 80s that
has beautiful theoretical properties
very attractive ones uh but it is
defined only over monoton functions over
sets this is what it does
so um people have studied the extensions
of data logs to negation and to
aggregate
but today I want to show you the a
particular way of thinking about
extending data log by using semi-rings
by extending extending it to summaries
it's an algebraic approach to extending
data log
yeah this is this is the agenda so there
will be two lectures the first lecture
is going to be very basic so it's going
to be a little bit boring
um it's going I'm going to give a quick
background on data log for the extremely
few among you who are not more experts
in data in data logs than I am
um and I'm going to describe some some
basic techniques from partial orders and
from semi rings that we use to reason
about termination of extensions of data
to semiotics
and the second lecture will be a little
bit more technical I'm going to talk
about polynomial equations and how to
region in general about termination and
hopefully I have some time at the end to
talk about two beautiful Concepts uh
pretty old ones uh close semi-rings and
clean algebras
the main takeaway from both lectures is
that you can use algebraic properties of
the simulink in order to reason about
algorithmic properties of the extension
of data log to semi-rings and I find
this beautiful the fact that you can use
algebraic identities and what you know
about your simulink to quickly infer
something about the behavior of your
data or programs
okay so I hope you all were here at balt
stock yesterday
just to just to set the expectations
right it's about very high so I simply
gave up so you take what you get I'm
going to do my best to tell you about
these techniques they are beautiful but
I am not planning to Matchbox talk
good so let's talk start about talking
about data log
um and I apologize to people known in
the room who'd know a lot more about
data logs than I know how many people
never have never seen data log
okay okay good so good so I this is my
excuse
um so here is my quick introduction to
data log in three slides I'm going to
start with an example uh the example is
the following we are given an input
graph come on
here's my pointer what is my pointer
here uh so we are given an input graph
described as a binary relation
and there is one particular note and we
want to compute the set of all the nodes
reachable from a and if you can see this
graph which is not very visible these
nodes are b c and d h is not reachable
and neither are at the other ones I
often give this talk to an audience that
has many SQL practitioners and I need to
um to acknowledge that this is something
you can write in SQL but I don't
recommend it there are many problems
with it instead I recommend using data
log
a data log is a very simple language it
consists of rules
and the rules can be recursive and you
reason from right to left they are
exactly the same notation as we so in
the first day in hang stock and that we
saw yesterday in balstock on on
conjunctive queries uh here we have
three rules uh the first two they
compute the probability of closure of
the relation e and the last two to
compute unary set forth answer so how do
we compute a traditive closure well
every pair of nodes x y and the edge
relation is also in the transitive
closure and if we have a parax here the
prcy in the transitive closure and the
DH relation then X Y in the transitive
closure and finally
every node y connected to a interaction
closure should be in our answer that is
a data log
the order of the rules does not matter
you can interlib the rules in any order
you want
and in terms of terminology
the input relations the black ones in my
in my slides are the are called
extensional database predicates or edbs
and the output relations will be blue
they are called intentional database
predicates
okay so this is data log
um by example now uh the the beauty of
the data login that has a very elegant
semantics uh and in order to define the
semantics I need to Define a simple
concept quantity immediate consequence
operator
the immediate consequence operator is a
function that takes as input as state of
the idbs
incorporate like a partial computation
that we have done and computes a new
state of the idbs of those relations we
are computing
so in our toy example we consolidate the
first two rules into a single into a
single rule and the an immediate
consequence operator takes some partial
computation to try the disclosure and
computes a new state of the partial
computation of that around the diff
closure and does the same thing for the
answer set
in the literature there are three
different semantics for data log a model
theoretic semantics fixed Point
semantics a and a proof theoretic
semantics and they're all equivalent I'm
going to Grant algorithm extremely
quickly making some people here angry
the minimal model semantics is defined
in a much more elegant way but
algebraically is equivalent to saying
that we're looking for that state of the
idbs for which if we apply the immediate
consequence operator we get a subset of
that state of idbs
and the effects at least fixed Point
automatic sets that we want to get
equality
and there is a third semantic that I'm
glossing over
yes
for this equality but why is the model
semantics yeah so in the model semantics
I was um yeah so I didn't include this
is the theoretic semantics what you do
you convert each rule into an
implication so um you you keep your
teeth the same d as here and the third
style becomes an implication
uh and then the the
um a model is any state of the idbs for
which all the implications defined by
the data log rules hold
and you're looking for the minimal one
and the implication means subset
it doesn't mean implication in the
opposite direction
is foreign
like that yes
it satisfies some kind of one after
listening so that you have this
inclusion
exactly so the other question whether is
there some kind of monologicity uh and
the answer is yes the way we are going
to compute it we are going to increase
this this partial state
and if there are no more questions here
then I can show this right on the next
slide because it's a fundamental Concept
in data log this is how we compute the
output of a data work program we uh with
with something what that we call the
naive algorithms we start with the
empty state for all the ibps and then we
repeatedly apply the immediate
consequence operator Computing a large
General market State uh until uh it
stabilizes until we reach a fixed point
okay so to give you an example in our uh
Toy example with a transitive closure
and the set of reachable notes uh we
will start from the empty set for both
alternative closure and answer and then
we repeatedly apply the immediate
consequence operator getting larger and
larger set
okay an important observation here this
naive algorithm always terminates
and moreover it terminates in a number
of steps that is no more than the number
of ground atoms that you can construct
uh using of using the idb predicate and
using the constants that are given in
the input database and the uh input EDP
predicate
so what this means in this example uh is
that you look at the input relation e
which defines a graph and let's suppose
we have a little n nodes in that graph
so we can have at most N squared
possible tuples in the relation t
and at most nth in in answer so the
total number of topics that we can add
is at most N squared plus one which is
little K little N squared and I like to
ignore that little and I like to call
Big and the total number of such topics
that we can ever produce and this is an
upper bound to the number of iterations
okay
uh is data log clear
yes
and you cannot edit entries data log is
restricted to having only monotone roots
so if there are no more questions then
it's quiz time what do these days our
groups compute
they look pretty much like gravity
but uh here we have two occurrences of
the relation e and similarly here to
occur as a subsid relation e while here
on the on the left on the right
um the the variables are slightly
different so XC versus ZX
what do they compute
also free event line is perfect
and the other one
uh no data data log experts are not
allowed to
this is the same generation
very subtle
so here clearly we are completing path
of even lengths we start with a path of
length 2 and then we extend paths with
one note um what I should have left one
to the right this is more interesting so
here we start from a node uh D and both
um any two children of Z are uh and NT
and moreover if um
UV has the same uh have a common
uh if you need orange the same
generation and then their children X and
Y are also in the same generation are
you assuming undirected graphs I'm
assuming directed graphs
hope I got it right
I mean I'm pretty sure I got it right
two
two coming out of Z so you're looking at
the left the right on the right the
right we've got two edges coming out of
Z yeah so um um think about going from
left to right this is uh parent to child
so uh X and and Y have a common parent d
and here we are saying that if UV were
already in the same generation
then their children X and Y are also in
the same generation
rewards uh think about and a note and
look at two nodes X and Y if there is
the same distance from that common
ancestor then we say that X and Y are in
the same generation
this makes sense in a tree but you know
because the intuition a little bit
more
it makes sense in trees and then block
recyclers indeed
in English but uh the the message is
data log is a cool language you can
express interesting things on the other
hand it's also very limited
uh data log does not allow us to express
negation
because it insists on this elegant
semantics uh the least fixed point and
the minimal model and it does not have
aggregates
it's a second it's a second bullet that
is a that is a focus of this talk we
really want to to allow Aggregates and
data log and um this extensions of data
log with aggregate has been studied
since uh since the mid early 90s and
usually people have examples like the
bill of material
so here is an example where we would
need aggregate we have a set of Parts
called X
and for each part there is a cost C this
is a native cost of that part C
in addition there is a subpart relation
every part X might have a subpart y it
might have multiples of Parts y
and the the goal of this program
is to compute for every part X
the total cost
and the total cost is it is its own cost
C
plus the the total cost of all its
subpart and sub-sub parts which I called
with stock total subpart so how we store
the sub part well here we need to sum up
the total cost of the direct sub part of
x
what is important here is it's
interleaving between recursion so total
depends on total subpart which in terms
depends on total the interleaning of
recursion and aggregation
this makes the semantics more difficult
and it breaks standard semantics of data
okay there is a second example that you
find in the literature called the
company control example I thought it's a
very clever one but it's not too clever
so talk to me after the break and I can
I can explain you what goes on but the
same thing happens here there isn't
interleaving between summation aggregate
recursion and also a a threshold
condition so it may slightly it's
slightly more complicated
great so this is a the
topic of this talk so um
uh no I'm going to define a new approach
to defining these uh these semantics
that is based on uh or order simulinks
and then yes and then we will talk about
semantics
okay so um
I I just want to acknowledge the
extremely rich literature uh uh devoted
in the 90s and Beyond to defining and
extending data log to negation so there
are some really beautiful papers
um that proposed and studied stable
model semantics were founded semantics
and by lattices uh that entire
literature is really beautiful
uh the uh the work in the early 90s that
aimed to extend data with Aggregates
sometimes borrowed similar concepts for
example you can find um
semantics of min max aggregations based
on stable model semantics
but this is not the path I'm planning to
to discuss today but instead I want to
use semi-rings
I want to extend data log to um
to operate over the same rings
so this is in the spirit of valve stock
yesterday
but there is a little twist not
technically but in terms of
of
um of gold so in bad stock the the
semi-rings were annotations
uh designed to explain how a computation
has proceeded they were really
provenance annotations
I'm going to make this annotations first
class citizens those are the values that
we want to compute
same computation but really now they are
our output
so the bill of material example I want
to write something like this we have a
single relation called a unit relation
cost
that contains only the part but its
value now is that same urine annotation
is the actual cost of the part X
and uh the the
recursive program that computes the
total cost is written very naturally uh
it is is
some product expression like you saw in
Hong stock on Monday
it is a cost uh plus the the sum over or
the subpart of the total cost of that
subpart we are total is defined
recursively
this is how I would like to Define
um a data log so to do this extension we
need to extend the notion of SMU ring to
be partially ordered
so that is the topic of the next part
let's talk about partial orders
and then we will we will show how to
extend data log to to partially all the
siblings
Yes Albert
[Music]
h plus should be some what is this times
Well in this example think about time
speaking times multiplication which
means that if Y is indeed the support
then this is one
and if Y is not a support then this is
zero
and therefore you use some of the right
thing but you touch on a very um in a
very sensitive topic and I'm going to
come back to this
okay so let's talk about partially
ordinance and this is where I need to
apologize because this is very basic but
I want to make sure that you are all on
the same on the same
um the same speed structure holders he
said P is for the partial or the
secretary the binary relation uh we it's
reflected anti-symmetric and transitive
this is a partial order we would always
assume that P has the minimal element
which is bottom
and when there exists I'm going to
denote the least upper bound and
greatest lower bound with these uh these
symbols and notice at bottom is actually
the
um it is the greatest lower bound of the
entire set or the least upper Mount of
the empty set
okay very basic and of course a monotone
function is a function between two
possets that preserves the all the
relation
okay good so a simple example is the
standard example is like natural numbers
of Boolean they are nicely ordered here
is an interesting one remember then the
um the tropical semi-ring in the
tropical semining that bar showed you
there was a natural order which is
actually the reverse order
so I'm going to add infinity because
that's part part of the tropical
semi-ring and imagine ordering this set
in the opposite order
the smallest element is infinity
and when you grow you grow from Infinity
down to zero
it's kind of
make your your head spin
um there's a family of subsets the set
of subsets is partially ordered
um here is an important example uh again
from Power stock consider all the
polynomials with um you know in this
case over a single variable with integer
coefficients
we can partially order them by saying
that one polynomial is less than the
other if every coefficient of every of
every monomial is less than the
coefficient of the similar monomial and
the other polynomial
now an important concept that it's it's
very
um useful to to to apply when it applies
is that you come sometimes can lift
properties from a single set to products
so in the case of of partial orders we
can always organize a Cartesian product
of two partial orders by ordering the
the appear wise and similarly we can
take on any power of a partial order and
uh order it pairwise
yeah so watch for this construction
because uh it is relevant if you think
about C
uh
naive evaluation algorithm of data log
that needs to operate over multiple idb
predicates
that Tuple of idb predicates lives in a
Cartesian product of partial of partial
orders
so we will always come back to these
products
[Music]
yeah it's it's like here so it means um
uh the format it means a set of
functions from Omega to B
intuitively you can think of it as a set
of topics
where the elements in the doctors are
elements from B
and the number of elements in the Tuple
is this Omega each position in that
company is one element of Omega
but a quick way to think about this is
think about omega as being a number and
this is just P to that number
good let's talk about fixed points at
least fixed points so now we fix a
monotone function from a partially
ordered set to itself and we call x a
fixed point if f of x is X
standard fixed point we call it a prefix
point this is not not such a well-known
concept we call it a prefix point if x
of X is below X
obviously every fixed point is a prefix
point but not vice versa
and we are usually interested in the
list uh the least fixed Point uh or the
least prefix point and then we call it
the least fixed point of the least
preparation simple concept
uh we are going to what am I doing here
okay so yeah these are this should be
clear Concepts
good so yeah
um a little known simple fact
is that if you uh if you happen to have
a least prefix point
at least one at least prefix point then
that is also a least fixed point
so as you're trying to prove that your
function has a least fixed point
uh it's often convenient to prove that
it has a least prefix point and that is
also a lease fixed point
try to prove it as an exercise yesterday
yes
I should have said that we we always
assume that f is modern
otherwise yeah it doesn't make sense
actually it does make sense but we are
going to assume that f is model
interesting there's a Converse doesn't
hurt
uh you can have examples where there is
at least fixed point
and of course that's also a prefix point
but it's not the least one and there is
no least prefix point
make your head spin uh but uh remember
that you can only use this in one
direction from here to here
you can connect this to data log
remember we had two semantics the
minimal model semantics is the least
prefix point and the least fixed point
is at least fixed point and um
their equivalent is just an instance of
this literacy on them yes
it's one of these
right
because in the in the data log when you
define then this
is not an element right it's wholesale
uh yes
this requires a little bit of it like it
requires a little bit of care when we
talk about data log uh F this F will be
the immediate consequence operator
and uh p is the order set of all the
possible instances of the idb predicate
so uh when we look for a fixed point we
look for an instance of the idb
predicate
that are such that if we apply the
immediate con segment operator we get
the same the same result
yes
say anything about the uniqueness of the
fixed point or prefix Point okay uh so
quick hold uh is at least a list of the
this fixed point it's the least fixed
point you need
okay
because uh the least fixed Point must be
below every other fixed point
if you have a second one that you think
is also released well then you also have
the opposite uh inequality and since
um the partial order is anti-regular
anti-symmetric that means that the two
least fixed points must be the same
okay so let me see how am I doing on
time
I was wondering whether I should show
the proof of this but I shouldn't I
think I really invite you to prove this
it's a it's a one-liner two-liner and uh
it's really instructive proof that if Z
is a the least prefix point then uh it
is also a fixed point and moreover where
it is the least fixed point
us means a break how to how to prove it
good so um how do we how did we compute
the least uh fixed point for data log
we used the naive algorithm the native
evaluation algorithm and that extends to
any partially ordered set that extends
to Computing the the fixed point or the
release fixed point or that is prefix
point of every monoton function on a
partially ordered set and the I um the
um it consists of defining the sequence
we start from the empty set from the
sorry we start from bottom and then we
repeatedly apply the function f
obtaining an increasing sequence of
elements in the set key and this I've
seen the name um the term Clinic
sequence for this sequence especially in
papers by esparzan and I like the name
so let's call this
foreign
uh for any fixed Point not just at least
one uh he made with always above every
element of technicians
so by completing the cleaning sequence
you can never go wrong you can never
exceed a fixed Point not at least one
not any other
okay so this is the good uh
um but uh now you will ask me is uh is
the least upper bound of the clinic of
the community sequence the least fixed
point
and the answer is yes but we do need
some additional assumptions and they are
standard in the literature uh what
people do they require the process to
the Omega continuous
so let's define this
uh an Omega chain is a sequence of
increasing elements in the opposite
the cleaning sequence is an Omega chain
uh so the the partial order is called
Omega complete
a for every Omega chain the uh the least
upper Mount exists
and the function is called Omega
continuous if it commutes with the least
upper Mount of any Omega Gene
and in that case it's not hard to see
that he uh the least the cleaning
sequence the least upper amount of
community sequence exist and it is the
least fixed one
it's important to look at some examples
here so um
the the set of natural numbers uh with a
standard order is not omega complete
because you can grow and grow and grow
and never reach uh there is no list
upper mouth but if we add infinity
they're doing a very good shape then it
becomes an Omega complete set
uh interestingly remember the tropical
semi ring which has a reverse order
this is Omega Complete because you can
never if you can never decrease uh for
too long yeah it can only decrease the
finite amount of time
here are non-examples of course just the
natural numbers it's not omega copy the
set of polynomials uh very important for
for our discussion soon it is not omega
complete
uh and even if you extend the
coefficients uh to include Infinity
this set is still not omega complete
so how can we make it Omega complete any
guesses
understand why it is NX is not
what
because it is
yeah good observation so why why is this
not omega complete so deeper pointed out
because this is not omega complete so if
you just take constant here you can grow
and grow those constants forever
okay so I'm fixing this by saying that
let's allow the coefficients of the
monomials to include Infinity
power series
so uh not extreme Infinity because the
power supply chain do not necessarily
grow but I make it a power series
okay so this will come into and to play
later uh okay so just to summarize why
we care about economical complete set is
because then
um sequence
yes and I'm sorry for intervening in
this manner but I'd like to share with
you
know
continuity is there's no accident that
for Kevin can tell me if I'm saying
stupid things please uh there's an
accident that continuity of this kind
actually arises in conjunction with
streaming because he was proving fixed
Point theorems for computational
yes for recursion Theory and
computational phenomena
and
similarly this comes up a lot in the
semantics of programming languages in
the work of Dana Scott and many others
so so there is something about
continuityilities of special interest to
computer scientists because of the
computational nature
mathematicians will do very abstract
work they probably you know do not care
you know Ultra filters and what have you
they may not care that much about Omega
continuity but for US computer science
is very important
wrong
I don't disagree and that's pointing out
that this fact was not to canister and
to touch independently late 30s clinical
his PSD 1941 but their proof was
different
last sentence
the in a concrete ladies and he took the
ins of the set of all prefix points
soups in it and you take the INF you can
show that that is a least prefix point
and yes okay
if I remember correctly it takes a
complete lattice and uh and proves that
um the the set of of fixed point is
actually itself a complete lattices
and the reason is because you intersects
the set of least prefix points uh which
is a complete lattice with a set of
greatest with of least often you
intersect see the prefix points which is
a complete lattice with the post fixed
points which is also complete lattice
intersection of two complete lattice is
a complete lattice and that is that
happens to be the fixed
uh interestingly that actually we don't
care about that
because all the examples that I'm aware
of they are Omega continuous so I can't
talk about Delta continuity or about L
continuity all these beautiful Concepts
um from from algebra because there is no
need Omega continues everything I've
seen is Omega continues you can
construct artificial examples which are
not yes
can you always complete the full sets to
all your computer ah cool question
because this is why you need to come to
the second lecture
okay I will show you how to do it it's
actually trivia
not not one element I think about it yes
think about n times n
okay uh so why why do we spend time on
this slide well because of this because
then we have um uh every continuous
function has at least fixed point and we
are done
here is where we diverge from the
classical work
I want the naive algorithm to terminate
in a finite number of steps I don't want
to compute this this increasing sequence
Forever This is we don't want to do this
we want the algorithm to actually
determinate uh so when does this happen
when is the cleaning sequence finite
because uh if it's finite then the least
fixed point of f is one of the terms of
the cleaning sequence
again a beautiful concept that you find
in many papers in the literature is that
of the ascending chain condition
so we say that at both set satisfied the
sending chain condition
if for every Omega chain if every Omega
chain is finite
so for every Omega chain there exists in
an index such that from there on all the
elements are equal
okay so examples uh remember the
tropical semiring
is infinity as it looks it actually has
satisfy the ACC condition you start from
Infinity but you cannot go down for too
long you need to stop
very interesting uh in the opposite in
the normal Direction you can grow
infinitely many times so you don't
satisfy the ECC condition and here is a
catch if we Define the tropical semi
ring over the Rios
uh then uh this does not satisfy the ACC
condition you can decrease forever
yes so subtle subtle notion uh good what
about the product
so if uh if we have two possets that
satisfy the ascending chain conditions
so does their product
it requires a little bit of proof and uh
so does a power a finite power of that
um
but not an infinite power so we have to
be careful
okay good so um again how do why do we
care about this we care about this
because in that case the least fixed
point of uh of any function or any
monotone function doesn't have to be
continuous or anything uh if if we if
the agency condition is satisfied then
the least fixed point is one of these
terms of the cleaning sequence when we
are in good shape
yes Paris so this condition uh implies
that you're also Omega completed and
mechanism yeah I removed that from the
slide because there's too much but yeah
I think it implies that you can set this
Omega complete and implies that every
monotone function is Omega continuous
thank you
good how do we check ACC
how do we look at it when you have a
simple sufficient condition to check the
ACC foundation and the answer is yes uh
there is this nice notion that people
also use often as a literature called
the rank of a post set and I I'm using
the definition from a beautiful Book on
a numerative combinatorics by Stanley I
strongly recommend this book
um and uh he defines the the rank of a
strictly increasing chain to be the
index of the last element of the chain
uh where you have to start by numbering
them from zero
okay this is the rank of a strictly
increasing sequence and the rank of a
bow set of a partially ordered set if
the largest rank of any strictly
increasing sequence yes Carl
okay this is interesting
okay is that is around clear
okay quiz time what is the rank of the
set of booleans
what is the longest sequence you can
construct
another equality one because we start
from zero and this is one
it's actually it Matrix this is why is
so don't uh don't ask me why did I start
enumerating from zero BC you have to
start from zero otherwise it does it's
not nice we want it to be nice what's
the rank of a power set
of Omega very nice what is the rank of
our uh nice um tropical simulink where
you cannot cannot grow forever
this is infinity all the sequences are
finite but you can construct them bigger
and bigger interestingly
um so finite rank obviously implies CCC
but not vice versa
what about the products we care about a
lot about the products uh where the rank
of a product is the sum of the ranks
this is where it really matters that you
start from zero to get these nice
expressions
is the rank of a power is the size of
subset times the rank of B
and obviously if the rank of a partially
order set is R then the least fixed
point of f is
the the cleaning sequence at step r or
even earlier
right so this was my
tutorial on very Basics
facts from about partially ordered sets
so let's just summarize uh one thing too
is that it's worth remembering is that
if you're looking for the for the least
fixed point it suffices to look for the
least prefix point and sometimes it's
easier to prove that you have at least
prefix point
uh
Omega completeness and Omega continuity
which always happens in in our world of
database applications that implies that
the least fixed point of uh of a
function is the least upper bound of the
cleaning sequence
and finally if you are lucky and your
set has a finite rank uh that implies
the ACC Foundation uh if you just have
the ACC condition that it's enough to
imply that the cleaning sequence is
finite
and
um and and therefore the you can compute
the least fixed point in a finite number
of steps
with any questions so far about about
partially ordered set
yes
it gets closer and closer to something I
thought honestly if you if you if you
takes any software bound then this
convergence happens but I'm not aware of
how to expose this in a practical
anesthetic although I have some things
to say towards the end of the last of
the next lecture some beautiful Concepts
good good so now we are finally ready to
extend data log uh uh to from from set
to semi-rings
so what do we need for this uh we
already know uh from the lectures by
hang and by Bal how to extend
conjunctive queries or even unions of
conjunctive queries to semi-rings this
is what Paul did for for provenance this
is what Hank Did with Syria numbers so
we know how to interpret those
conjunctive queries over over semi rings
so data log is of course defined over
sets so we want to also Define it over
semi-rings but it requires a partial
order
we required that partial order in order
to compute the fixed point in order to
guarantee that it exists or in order to
check if the naive algorith terminates
in a finite number of steps so for that
we need to ensure that a semi-rink we
are we are defining data log over is
also ordered
and I'm going to do this in the simplest
possible way
uh but before I show you the definition
I need to explain to you what a
pre-semuring is we know what the
semi-ring is what is a pre-semi ring and
I put it here on the bottom so a
pre-semi ring does not require that x
times 0 is equal to zero
here it just dropped that condition
actually in the literature you sometimes
find people defining a semi-ring without
this condition and they don't call it a
presenting but the correct terminology
today seems to be that we call this a
pre-semuring if we don't exist in that
condition
and I don't want to insist on it because
some some concrete examples of
application they are actually
pre-semorings are not the same Rings yes
Paris
hey when we talk about provenance we
want to have this and now when we talk
about data log we don't want to have
this
um it's just a um
it allows you some some semi rings that
I care about uh for for a data log
applications that were not interesting
for provenance applications that's all
there is
because if you want to maintain this
concept that zero is the people of an
absent Tuple
then this would mean that you take the
you know a joint of a tuple with an
absent Tuple yeah
that's true so good so if you didn't
have that some relational optimization
break or something but you know as
always you can
yeah we can have a more interesting
discussion once we see some examples I
think there was another question here I
was asking asking which submarine uh
which pre-simmering is not the smearing
that you're interested in yeah I I have
one example in a couple of flights but
first let me uh show you how we extend a
uh same reading or a presenting to a
partial order uh in a most brutal way
I'm just going to say that this
structure is a partially ordered
pre-semi ring or a pops uh if it
consists of a pre-seminine and a partial
order with the bottom such that
additional multiplication are monotone
and and this is a condition there I
might
question whether it be needed or I I
need it for the next slide but you can
also
contemplate dropping this condition so
I'm going to insist at bottom times x is
bottom
so this will satisfy ball to some extent
if you don't want a tuple you just
annotated this bottom you don't annotate
it with zero
and when zero equals bottom completely
happy and when the zero which will
happen in most cases then uh then we are
completely happy
okay so two simple properties
the first one is Trivial it's a trivial
exercise in any pops bottom plus bottom
is bottom
the second one is really important
and it actually simplifies the
discussion makes you wonder why do I
even talk about box
um take any partially ordered
pre-summering Define its core
to be the set of all elements of the
form X Plus bottom
we can organize this as a pre-summering
using the inherited operations plus and
multiplication uh the the identity is
going to be zero plus bottom the
identity for multiplication is one plus
bottom
it turns out that this set is always a
semi ring
so it will satisfy this identity
and moreover it is a naturally ordered
semi-ring
that is a cool exercise yes well is the
plus that you use there in X Plus bottom
and formal enjoyment or is it actually
the classic the same building that is it
gives you another element
it it gives you another another element
this is a subset of coffee
okay so proving that it's part not
naturally or that requires a little bit
of thinking with with a one-liner
interesting exercise good so uh what was
a naturally ordered semi-ring
seriously
for that bottom or bottom time sorry
take it back
so just
okay
I want this one later
yes yeah I mean you Pops it on this very
commutative
oh I forgot to mention this all the same
earrings that I'm considering are
commutative
okay good so what was a naturally
ordered simulink uh you cannot actually
people sometimes Define a natural order
even on the pre-semiting uh remember
that in any simulating or pre-semiting
you can Define this relation X is less
than y if there exists a g such that X
Plus Z is equal to y
this is always primitive it's always
reflexive
uh but it's not necessarily
anti-symmetric when it is then uh we we
call it a the natural order and in that
case we say that s is not already
ordered
when s is naturally ordered when it is a
a semi-ring and it is naturally ordered
then of course it's also a pops because
it just take that natural order and
Define it into your user order and the
core
the core is itself because zero is just
bottom
so finally I get to pierce example here
is an example which I think is very very
useful for for numerical applications
uh it takes a set of real numbers
and extend them with bottom the set of
three and numbers I should remind you is
not a naturally ordered semi ring the
natural order is not it's not connected
to the same meaning in an interesting
way when you compute a fixed point you
don't want to start from minus infinity
from the smallest element
uh so the order in the area doesn't help
us instead what you can do you can add
you can add an artificial an artificial
element button this is what people do in
the notational semantics are they an
artificial element bottom and simply
extend the operations plus and times uh
to board them to touch the bottom plus
axis bottom bottom times x is bottom
so everything bottom is less than
everything nothing else is comparable
here the core is trivial the core is
just element bottom because whatever
you're adding to bottom you're getting
bottom
okay so I hope this explains why uh I I
really care about about capturing this
example and there is another one called
the four the four lattice which is also
used for example of of a police American
yes
okay I can show you uh and Camilo water
on this
yeah so the order is bottom is below
everything
else is comparable
think of about bottom it's being
undefined everything else is defined and
once it's defined here there is no no
more comparison
good so finally we can extend data log
to semorings and we'll be extend it I'm
going to put a ring here at the top and
then we are going to call it data robot
because it's over simulink so um this is
a pretty disappointing slide because
it's very simple what we are going to do
we are going to replace a standard
relations over sets with speed relations
where p is our chosen partially ordered
presenting
so the the relations now then associate
to each Tuple and element from this
partially ordered uh presuming The
Operators that we use in data logs they
become the operator that are going to
replace with operators in the same ring
so for example we had a data log rule
like this and now this becomes a data
local like that where the operators are
now operated from smyrink and the
relation to RP relations
this one is that a finite song
and is this a finite sum that's a very
good uh uh
right uh it I'll come back to this
and the rest follows naturally the
semantics will be the least fixed point
of the immediate consequence operator
cases can be defined using and it can be
computed using the naive evaporation
algories if it terminates not clear
anymore
uh and uh the naive algorithms a
cleaning sequence
um this is increasing sequence that
hopefully will terminate and we will
discuss when it telling this and when it
doesn't
cool examples
so here is how we search a program looks
and data logo it's impossible to read
but uh it actually becomes very clear
when you instantiate it to concrete semi
Rings or concrete partially ordered
pre-semitis and here are two instantiate
the instantiations uh we can instantiate
it over
and then this computes a set of nodes X
reachable from a exactly what we had
before or we can instantiate it over the
tropical semi ring where the operators
become a Min and plus
and then we compute the single Source
short response from a because we are
seeing that the the the distance from a
to a node X
the distance from a to a node X is zero
if x is a or it is a smallest possible
values of the distances from A to Z Plus
the length of the Edge from D to X
algorithm work here I'm going to show
you a simple example just to convince
you that it's it's the right cleaning
sequence so we would start with the
grounding of this relation R to be
Infinity which is the smallest element
in the in the tropical centering and
then we repeatedly apply this Rule and
we grow and grow and grow this tropical
semi and growing is is bizarre because
we go from Infinity to over zero until
we reach a fixed one
thank you
okay
um and notice that this is um actually
it's kind of it's related to the way
that um uh adjacency Matrix that Nicor
show does showed us yesterday
yeah that's it's exactly it is the same
computation
I want to show you one cool example and
this guy kind of illustrates the power
and limitations of extending data log to
to um priests and meetings namely the
bill of material example
which looks like this the the total cost
and now here I call the two the total
cost of a part X is uh its own Cost Plus
the sum of all the um
or the total cost of all the support
so here I wrote this a little bit
differently and I will explain it a
second why I didn't multiply them
anymore
okay so um this program of course will
work fine if your subpart hierarchy is a
tree
even if it is a dark you might question
what it computes if it's a dark I don't
worry about what it computer I worry
about termination
uh the question is what happens if your
your sub part is the cyclic graph it
probably is not having any real
applications but I'm interested in
determination what happens to this
program if the Soft part has a cycle
like it has right here
so now it depends in which semi ring I
interpret this program
I can interpret this over the same ring
of natural numbers
this is naturally ordered so we start
from zero and we repeatedly apply the
immediate consequence operator and the
the ground the values of these grounded
atoms they grow and grow and grow and
obviously on the cycle they will diverge
they will grow forever
so this on this semi-ring the the
program libraries but there is a second
interpretation remember the lifted reals
this is where they become very useful so
with the lifted reals we start by
initializing all the values to bottom
and then we repeatedly apply apply the
immediate consequence operator and we
grow growing means that we can only grow
from bottom to a value
uh and now we terminate
uh yeah so this is a beauty of the of
the lifted reals this is why people use
this in the notational semantics of
programming languages uh when we
it has a well-defined semantics even
where if there are Cycles in the the
ground ground the ground
so you don't have examples but the
weights could be negative
good point these weights can be negative
I think they're wanted to see negative
weight
yeah you want it okay sorry okay
here is a key observation so I know I'm
running a lot of time but I want to
insist on that observation yes why
didn't we have the number one in q1 and
then C okay that means the number one
uh
so the the issue is that as long as this
value is bottom
uh you don't get anything because the
cross plus bottom is is bottom okay and
this is a little the little annoying
part I can't multiply Here If I multiply
then even 0 times bottom is still bottom
and then I can't make progress so I need
to separate this um I I need to have a
little bit of logic here to control
which um or to control how to ground
that program okay I don't want to talk
more about this I want to share
something really really important and
then maybe it's time to take a break
notice
without some notes on a uh on the cycle
their values can never Escape bottom
okay and this generalizes it uh the
notes on on a cycle can never Escape
the chords emiring
so that means that as we investigate
elimination of the of the program uh it
suffices to focus on a natural ordered
semi links so order is again restored in
the universe we don't need to worry
about anything other than the naturally
order scenario
okay good so uh let me skip these simple
properties
um let me skip what we learned because I
know everybody wants to take a break
but now it's waste time I'm going to
leave this on on on during the break uh
for you to to ponder what do these
programs compute here at the top uh we
have a very simple graph it's a chain uh
every Edge has a weight one uh this
program here computes coming off
transitive closure but what is the value
from 0 to n what is the numerical value
and similarly for the second and for the
Third
good so thank you folks um let's resume
after
[Applause]
wards